there is actually a dark hour movie
coming out right I didn't imagine it so
my friend Ryan mentioned to me today and
it certainly is really odd he mentioned
that the movie The Dark Tower is
currently scheduled to hit theaters in
about four months four and a half months
my immediate response was really that
soon I think in my head I had assumed it
wasn't coming out to the fall maybe
September October even do a Halloween
push on it but no it's still scheduled
for July now that's best moved back from
a previous release data it had but it's
still there and the reason that
stressing is odd is we haven't seen much
on this thing yet I mean I I just to
make sure that I wasn't like imposing
unrealistic expectations for a marketing
push on this thing I took a quick look
at the other major releases for July and
it's spider-man homecoming and it's war
for the Planet of the Apes and it's
Dunkirk and and human valerian and the
back is it valerian in the city of a
thousand planets I think is what it's
called the Lupus on things are coming
out all of those have had if not full on
trailers they've had some degree of
cheese or some kind of footage some kind
of something come out and Dark Tower
kind of has nothing and that's I kind of
gets me nervous and I I assure wait I'm
not overly invested in The Dark Tower I
haven't read the book so my own personal
investing on this thing's pretty low but
it was a big ambitious thing and I I
don't like the feel that I'm getting
that this big ambitious bold move with a
really phenomenal two leads cast and the
thing that we've got Matthew McConaughey
Ezra Salva is quietly falling apart I
mean this thing not cheap to make and
then and again and they haven't
cancelled this yes theoretically it's
supposed to be a like a accompanying TV
series next year and there's been no
word on that so I've got
I've got a couple of thoughts on what
might be going on one possibility is
that they're buying schedule and they're
going to bump it again to even later and
they just have it announced in a day yet
that's possibility number one
possibility number two whatever has been
created so far that the studio would
Columbia Pictures which is owned by Sony
whatever that they've seen they have a
strong dislike for and they're just
going to let this thing quietly die in
the theater that's a possibility another
possibility is that regardless of the
actual quality of the film they don't
have the marketing budget to really put
it by this because Columbia and Sony
they had a real bad 2016 and 2017
they've got one sure thing in the form
of threat amman homecoming but i don't i
don't know if they actually hit the
profit share with Marvel on that they
might say might not I'm pretty sure that
hasn't been made public but definitely
that thing sells itself I mean last year
that they did okay with some other big
budget stuff like sausage party the
shallows but their big stuff their ten
pool stuff passengers ghostbusters it
didn't do great and I wonder if they're
second-guessing what they want to put a
ton of money behind and Dark Tower it
given that they placed it in a
blockbuster
you know slot in terms of when it's
being released it's a bit of a tough
sell as a blockbuster because it's dark
and it's literary and it doesn't lend
itself necessary to the kind of
whiz-bang stuff that was normally
associated with a big temple blockbuster
and and that might be the other thing it
might just be that they don't know how
to market this thing regardless of
whether or not they're prepared or are
able to put much money behind the
marketing of it and that's not me
implying that Sony or Columbia Pictures
is somehow broke but in the wake of what
a big push they put behind something
like ghostbusters they might be
reassessing how much money they want to
put behind the marketing pushes and or
which movies they want to do it for I
hope that we get something soon whether
it's a trailer or announcement of the
new release they are just something
because it just it seemed like a really
interesting
project and it's I'm afraid it's just
going to get swept under the rug again I
don't know that for certain but it's
just a just a vibe I'm getting right now
and hope it's not the case so dark tower
what do you think come home with this
thing whatever it is drop low down on
the comments let's talk about it don't
forget to Like subscribe check me out on
Twitter I counsel of geeks give a listen
to the council of geeks podcast
available on iTunes and stitcher and
until next time this council is
adjourned